[Music]
and put your money where your mouth is
news you dirty like this
I don't do it submitted by desert on
your shirt the two S's are 1s desert on
your shirts no it's desert odd deserts
is that a sex thing I guess I don't know
kind of makes sense if you think like
golden shower like one of those things
where it's like there's a code name no
like I'm gonna come on you like whipped
cream tits yes whipped cream it's gotta
be that oh I've got tired of that in
high school then move on to bigger
better things like cream pie but we
could move on to this article are you
sure you won't talk about the cream by
Oakland no I talked about a lot today
okay a college student owes more than
two hundred thousand dollars to st. Jude
after her fundraising tweet went viral
oh no Jude the hospital yeah okay she
lying little liar Oh was she oh she was
trying to raise money and use this as a
she owed more money after she went viral
so this was her tweet what in the world
this time of year is about giving this
year I'm giving back to st. Jude and the
families who are supported by their
amazing services every favorite is 25
cents every retweet is 50 cents go give
go see Jude oh [ __ ] she meant for them
to give not for her no like she won't
gave out of her own pocket she thought
she'd get like 17 retweets 600 followers
on Twitter sell her house dude whoa
why would it get out of hand though like
that's the I don't say retweet in that
tweet hmm I would personally personally
not want to retweet it cuz I don't see
anything to retweet about it it's a free
thing for you to do and she's claiming
that she won't pay out of it it's what
everyone's doing now it's you don't have
to do charity yourself you just retweet
something and then somebody else does
charity for you yeah good afterwards
like I did something you did something
you did a lot for charity today yeah
they call it's something they have a
thing it's like all that people have
been posting about the fires but then
I'm not not gonna do any they're not
gonna save any animals but they just
want to keep out there's a fire over
there
watch out spreading awareness awareness
exaggerating awareness Amin that's
always say that I'm like what are you
doing when you post [ __ ] online
that's not activism I'm spreading
awareness or something like that
I'm feeling good about myself and
showing everyone how what a good person
I am while I do not think passive
activism her name is Dani
she's a 19 year old college student at
the Washington State University since
her tweet went viral a lot of people
were saying like how is she gonna pay
this cuz she ended up just to be a
stripper now or something more than
$200,000 because of how many how much
action sheet I would delete the tweet
and say oh sorry guys I [ __ ] up this
was meant for friends and family man
yeah I don't have this many face with me
I would have deleted that's why you
gotta include a hard cat you gotta
include art up until the $3.00 yeah once
it hit 50 favorites I would like delete
once it soars past Chipotle money I know
how honorable is that though she's like
oh my god it happened I have to do it
now I gotta do it cuz me I'll run away
like a [ __ ] it's not honorable
because they build her and you know
who's a Jew came with my money
that's what right no I was about to say
I st. Jude hospital came I was like yo
what the [ __ ] yo what the [ __ ] bro it's
like hey we're st. Jude like with my
money what the hell's going on you know
we got two hundred thousand retweets yo
what's going on here huh Italian grease
would you think we were Kaiser
Permanente's tweeting ha wowza okay so
we are stopping it here
people like [ __ ] that leave a mark yeah
this is what Danny looks like I'm sorry
that's a funny photo okay why would they
put that I thought let's see you in
front of a Christmas tree David yeah
same thing huh I'm under the F riot
yeah and though because it looks like
she's going yeah
like yeah hey look like you'd like
really [ __ ] up you know yeah yeah so
obviously she can't donate that much
money so she ended up starting up a
GoFundMe page for people who really how
much you want to bet there's nothing in
that thing right she's getting deeper in
this thing about 94,000 what's her whole
thing like is it specific for like
cancer children's or like what is it for
st. Jude Children's Hospital like they
just have it's just for children it's
for anything that the children are
floated with I think right or it's an
actual it's a hospital right but I was
just wondering if there was like a
specific cause like she was like Oh kids
with cancer or kids with bad haircuts
like what is it for
I think it's kids who have cancer oh I
think it's kid with bull haircuts that
needs that's the thing that should
happen I had a bowl haircut too much -
holiday there are a lot of horrible
haircuts happening let's let's go for me
and get some nice wigs for these kids or
something like that
I like it yeah it is it's telling cancer
and other life-threatening diseases oh
man I never started a charity yeah you
don't believe it right you say that how
would you do that to yourself yeah you
know what he's doing I donated and I did
charity work I done i-i'll do labor
I'll never start one yeah why is every
celebrity need to charity exactly like
every football player has a charity of
their own I will start one he just said
I'll never start with I'll start one you
dig it holes man nonprofit dog Care
Center is a dog sanctuary
that's a nonprofit yeah I'll do that one
that's pretty good that's a good tax
shelter move mm-hmm that's what it
sounds like Danny here she ended up
partnering up with Kmart cuz Kmart
reached out to her team I thought they
were going bankrupt and like
disappearing I'm glad that they're still
here
they've been along that money so Kmart
has been
long-standing partner of Saint Jude and
so they took part in the fundraising and
so they held an official Danny Messina
day which is her name
where customers had the option to donate
money to st. Jude and it would go
towards Danny's death here that's always
the worst we have to close his store
right and you check it out and they're
like do you want to donate to st. Jude's
Research Hospital and you're like no you
pretty much have to I always say no you
say no yeah even come at like Petsmart
like would you like to donate to a
animal shelter in my flock no you know
what they're basically asking you at
that point is that do you want to be a
decent human being today
right that's what they're saying to you
right now in front of the whole [ __ ]
line right [ __ ] [ __ ] but I go to
the shelter and I bring those dogs home
I don't need a donate a [ __ ] dollar I
don't need to go to the shelter to bring
the dogs home I just don't need a dog at
the gross store and I buy yogurt plus I
want to see where the actual money goes
I want to see the accounting behind it
because I don't know me most of these
the huge s like non profits it goes to
admin if you [ __ ] what do you call it
audit them every couple of years they
get busted for some [ __ ] egregious
error they made and and then it just
goes away out of the news like pretty
quickly my cousin's a CPA and he wanted
he was doing this like for he was
working with a lot of nonprofits and he
had to leave that whole stuff because
some of these guys they have corner
penthouse offices and he's like why why
are you spending the [ __ ] people's
money on these ten thousand a month
office or whatever is like how come all
this money is going into admin and
you're spending like 15% on the actual
thing that's why are you in New York New
York like like like looking it with a
bay window at the skyline you know [ __ ]
like that it's like come on dude like
you can save so much money not being
there
it's a [ __ ] money grab dude that's
why I can't give to these things I don't
know I'm skeptical you know but a
grassroots see like five people getting
together hey Joe you know we're gonna go
[ __ ] give some sandwiches to some
homeless people and I'm like cool all
over but now they could save
let's give some cats and feed them some
cereal and [ __ ] alright alright let's
give him some milk
okay I'm Theriot do you would you do the
dog you 100 you know what no I take it
back I will do a charity I'll do one its
I would do a school like I would do my
own brainwashing system because oh [ __ ]
re-education yeah yeah I will teach them
like real life skills like how to open
up a [ __ ] bank account how to manage
your fine ass real life skills you know
like you're supposed to learn that at
home but your parents are [ __ ] stupid
to probably can't manage their money and
[ __ ] so like everybody's not there's no
upward mobility like it's just straight
up loser ISM see I think and I really do
mean this that there should be a way to
teach very young like I wish I was
taught when I was young how to [ __ ] well
cuz then I would teach you this well
hopefully a teacher with experience or
who knows what they're talking about the
sex ed teacher and that way by the time
that you're in your 30s you're a [ __ ]
master instead of like you know in your
30s you're kind of like everyone's a
[ __ ] master now that's the norm people
will be happier in the world the world
would be a happier place if I learn how
to [ __ ] when I was young I would have
been a much everybody feels bad for
their first girl yeah like you know like
16 when you kind of learn when you get
into that [ __ ] and I'm saying that's
true they'll be tight right like ut they
teach you cuz I like believe me like for
a long time like I [ __ ] like I went to
public school yeah you know saying like
I wanted to [ __ ] like I had a [ __ ]
degree like I went public school they
give you like shitty education yeah
that's the stereotype his [ __ ] education
was really shitty so he [ __ ] suck
that sex I want to [ __ ] like I went to
Harvard
yeah see yo no saying like I went to
Harvard Law
so like cardigan and [ __ ] I don't
even think I don't think you should ever
be judged by the first person you have
sex with that's not even fair
could you don't know what's going on
right it's either why did why don't you
know what's going on because you were
just taught like this is the vagina the
blood flows here like I know where the
blood flows I don't know how to [ __ ]
work it yeah they didn't tell us about
the clitoris no they didn't say one word
about it why not
mm-hmm I would love to know what the
hell that was cuz that was a I'll tell
you this right now when I was with my
first girlfriend that was a pretty big
surprise finding that thing down there
excuse me what do you have a speed back
like the [ __ ] is this is it a little
dick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]